talk and approximate optimality with
bounded regret in Dynamic matching
models so thank you for the invitation
and uh um I will uh uh present uh
um let's say an effort that has been
going on for a couple of years to
develop uh a new class of uh queuing
models that uh we call Dynamic matching
models and and uh uh the focus uh will
be on the optimization and this part is
uh joint work with Shan mine that is
here and uh I will give overview of
previous results uh that uh uh have been
done uh in collaboration with people uh
um in Europe um us and uh also with
gidon from Israel so
um what is a what do we consider as
Dynamic match models uh well uh if you
um uh look at the talks we had
previously uh this week and uh um many
of them had some uh matching uh flavor
um for example uh talks that around
uh systems that model shared economy uh
shared rides or uh maybe ads uh but uh
also uh classical matching models are
not no longer really uh enough because
uh more and more we have sto
stochasticity in the system and so uh we
have um stochastic arrivals of uh both
populations so the idea here is uh to uh
uh BR uh to construct a bridge between
uh matching models and classical queuing
Theory uh as you may know uh uh queing
Theory uh has been a uh a really uh good
success story in modeling of
communication networks uh and matching
has been uh really useful in uh economy
so bringing those two together uh in
idea uh that we might have uh some new
theoretical tools uh for modeling the
changes uh in uh our societal uh systems
today
so uh I will uh first give some
background on uh uh biper matching model
and uh uh What uh uh what kind of uh um
queing systems we will consider and then
the main part of the uh uh talk we will
we will concentrate on the optimization
in these
systems okay so just to fix the notation
uh if we look at the static setting of
bip parted matching then uh we have a
bip parted graph uh on one side you have
demand classes and demand nodes and on
the other side you have Supply and there
is some uh
compatibility uh uh graph uh matching
graph that denotes all the possible uh
uh pairs we can make and uh uh
so I will denote by uh DFS uh
the U uh all the classes uh that can be
matched with a supply item of Type S and
similarly for uh s ofd uh then a
configuration in this uh uh in this uh
model is given by a vector X where x i
denotes the number of elements of each
type so uh at each node you can have
several uh items of a given class and uh
then uh in the starting setting we have
um H Mar marriage theorum that gives us
the uh um necessary and sufficient
conditions for existence of perfect
matching okay and uh these are what is
what is the type of so uh XI denotes the
number of items of a given class I and
uh uh these are uh three class classes
of uh demand population and uh uh we
have also here uh each is on one but
it's not just one item it's h it
represents one class and there might be
multiple items sitting at each uh uh
okay uh that's why also we have uh uh
not just uh uh sets but really the
number of items that we need to take
into
account uh okay so uh if you look look
at the uh systems today then more and
more often uh we don't have the static
setting but we have some uh arrivals uh
some arrival process both of supply and
demand and uh here is one uh example uh
kidne uh leing uh kidney donation
program uh where uh there is a patient
that needs a uh a kidney and there is a
friend or a family member that uh is
willing to donate uh a kidney but
unfortunately they're not compatible so
in that case they can sign up for uh uh
into a a living donor program and uh uh
wait until uh they receive a compatible
match so uh okay there are many other uh
restrictions if we really want to
consider this uh application but uh the
uh uh high level uh property of this
system system is uh that we have a
bipart uh graph and for compatibility
and we have uh stochasticity uh both on
the supply and on the demand
side so um another
uh um example where we need uh uh uh to
take into account uh stochastic arrivals
uh is the example of uh public housing
uh in Boston area so this is uh now
quite old example but uh uh it's a a
very similar story uh you have uh uh
families that apply for public housing
and uh they might uh specify some uh
requirements they want for example they
have uh young kid so there need needs to
be a school in the neighborhood um they
need a given surface uh uh to be able to
live in the house Etc and they might not
want to move into certain neighborhoods
uh because I don't know too far away
from their work uh or uh in any case uh
we have a bip parted graph that can uh
that models this uh uh compatibilities
between types of uh uh houses and types
of families and then uh we have uh
um stochastic arrivals of uh uh both
families and houses uh and uh we need to
uh uh pair them together uh in that case
uh because of transparence of the
program and uh uh
um it uh it didn't make sense to uh to
do um other thing than first come first
served uh policy which means that uh uh
a family uh that arrived first would get
the house that uh uh that was was there
sitting uh um and that uh they were
compatible with in many cases actually
families wait uh until the uh valuable
uh house is uh uh is there okay uh so
um for this specific uh first come first
serve uh policy uh now we have very
detailed results and uh uh this model
was first studied by uh uh C capan invis
in 2009 they uh um managed to describe
um uh dynamics of uh uh for simple
matching graphs uh such as uh um n model
which is just two uh types uh of uh
families two types of uh um houses and
then a bip parted graph that is a letter
N uh or more in general
for the
um graphs uh bip parted graphs that are
um almost complete in the sense that
there is only one uh Edge missing per uh
uh per
node well in that case Dynamics is very
uh simple and uh we only need to uh
track uh
um uh how many of items are sitting
there uh not the whole sequence uh of
the uh uh arrivals with their dates okay
that's why the system uh becomes much
more simple and uh
uh uh in the general case uh it's very
messy because you need to track really
who arrived first on both
sides so uh then uh uh initially uh they
wanted to uh understand uh how many of
uh what is the proportion of uh
um different types of houses that are
matched to different types of families
so what is proportion of each Edge uh
under all the uh uh pairs that we
observe so
uh then uh in uh uh
2012 uh finally this question was uh
answered for the general bipartite
graphs by using a product form uh
solution for a um slightly similar uh um
I mean for a similar uh queuing system
but uh uh that is different in the sense
that uh uh only demand arrives and the
uh Supply is actually Ser service in the
system and it's always present so it's
actually a queing model of type uh uh
call uh call center type of que
models so using that they were able to
answer answer uh what are the uh
matching rates uh for each uh Edge and
then uh now we manag uh to extend these
results and show reversibility of first
come first served policy and product
form under various State uh uh
descriptions that not only allow to uh
get this matching uh rates but also the
lengths of the links which is necessary
to study performance of the system
typically for the uh waiting time of uh
um of an item until it gets matched with
something and leaves the system
okay but uh uh this is Al all uh about
first Comfort served policy and in
practice uh this is not very easy to
implement for various reasons uh first
of all it's complex you need to track uh
imagine that your bip parted graph is
big so you need to track all the uh uh
all the sequence of unmatched items in
the system with exact dates when they
arrived uh in the system so first first
of all it might be a very long sequence
it might be uh uh costly to store this
but also uh you might not have this
information because uh of
confidentiality reasons because of uh uh
simply uh um it's uh it's not shared
with you
okay so uh the idea is now to consider
uh to um to relax this assumption that
uh or first come first served policy and
to consider um a more General uh demand
um I mean a more General uh Dynamic
matching models uh in which uh
uh we will uh uh uh so we uh we
uh we let the question of policy open
but we have a rest we will add a
restriction that the policy can uh
depend only on the number of items of
each type currently in the
system which will be much easier to uh
Implement and uh uh uh for uh for
applications so uh what is the model uh
now at each uh remember the static uh
setting had the bip parted graph now at
each node there is a
q uh we assume that uh uh the arrivals
happen in discrete time so uh at each
time there is uh one uh item that
arrives on the demand side and one item
that arrives on the supply side uh they
might not necessarily be compatible uh
and then
uh according to
the policy that we are going to choose
uh the activities that happen in the
systems in the system are instantaneous
matchings okay is that uh clear those
items that cannot be matched at a given
time T will be stored in the system and
will uh stay uh uh will build up in this
uh uh cues here so here for example if
we have a uh a blue arrival there and
brown here
uh we see that uh
uh for example the blue one can get
matched with yellow and this one has
choice between uh green and red and the
uh assume that uh it shows a right
so to
keep uh I uh
so I assume that uh current that at each
time there is uh at most one arrival on
each
side uh but uh uh in order to simplify
uh uh in order to simplify the uh the
presentation what is actually needed is
that over some uh longer period of time
the arrivals on both sides are balanced
that uh they're equal uh if this is not
satisfied then uh obviously uh what we
will uh obtain is uh uh random walk
online uh at in the best case uh and uh
what I don't understand is
um why can't you just cue everything and
then match it at the end uh so there you
you're assuming that if if there is an
available matching you have to match
or uh so uh not necessarily I open uh
this uh this is an excellent remark uh
we will see that uh uh an optimal policy
in this case will not do that will not
match in uh every time there is a uh a
compatible item you see everything and
then match it because it's uh infinite
time Horizon so yeah so I didn't
understand the
uh uh okay so uh and uh I mean uh for
this uh application of uh kidney
donation uh uh
uh living donors uh it made sense to
assume that there is one uh arrival of
uh Supply and one uh uh arrival of
demand at each time because they do
arrive in pairs in the general case you
might ask also why don't I
just uh consider a system where they
might abandon after a given time so I
don't have any restrictions on arrivals
uh well uh it turns out that this is
extremely difficult system to analyze so
uh having uh this restriction allows us
to have some uh theoretical results that
will give insights to good policies even
in the general uh case that's so that's
the idea here okay so
uh first question you might ask is uh uh
of course if uh these uh uh even under
this assumptions of one item on each
arriving on each side at each time step
uh is the system
stable and in the sense of whether the
uh uh Mark of underlying Mark of chain
model is a positive uh recurence and uh
uh so uh necessary condition are given
by uh uh generalization of how marriage
theorem it's uh actually exactly the
same uh conditions but with strict
inequalities
and uh uh the proof uh uses Network flow
arguments uh in graphs and uh so we
managed to show that uh uh there are uh
policies that only look into the current
uh amount of items of each type uh that
are also
uh that also have a maximum stability
region uh and uh uh one of these
policies is Max
W and uh uh there are policies such as
priority or uh so max weight here
corresponds to much the longest queue if
you have Choice look at who uh the queue
there there is the most item sitting and
uh choose that one uh so if you consider
the opposite which is probably the most
stupid thing you can do much the
shortest queue uh then this policy has a
non-trivial uh stability region but also
some priority policies that might make
sense uh have
non-al stability region so uh we managed
to prove the uh uh that the some
condition uh within the um this uh
maximum stability region well we
priority is not stable that also is not
uh uh trivial to show it so uh
experimentally you see it but then to
actually prove it it take some uh uh
some for the M do you always match
Whenever there is possible to match or
yes
for uh for even if you do that it's
stable so now uh the question is whether
this is a good idea whether we should do
that or not and uh uh as I said if you
try to optimize uh for example U uh
average Criterion this is not what
you're going to do you will have some um
threshold uh that will so what are you
what are you suggesting to optimize here
uh so uh
okay uh so I'll uh um I will be um I'll
I'll answer a question in in two
slides so uh here is just uh uh to uh
give you the uh uh the form of the uh uh
necessary uh stability conditions and uh
uh also nice uh uh uh side result is
that it's possible to uh to check these
conditions although there are strict
inequalities in uh
um polinomial time so it's uh it's not
always that trivial to check strict
inequality
conditions okay you have uh exponential
number of constraints here so what is Mu
mu is a distribution uh mu is the uh
arrival distribution so uh mu uh this is
marginal for the demand side and mu s is
marginal for the supply side
um so you need to solve Marx weight
matching for so when you saying Marx
weight if you have multiple arrivals
each time you need to do the max
marching
yeah so uh optimization so here is the
Criterion for the uh optimization
problem we'll consider uh some uh cost
function we will assume that it's linear
on Buffer levels yes just question on
the previous slide you you had an
assumption that the graph is connected
um Hulse theorem doesn't require an
assumption about the graph being
connected so so I don't really
understand why why you oh if the graph
here is not connected then it uh just
trally splits into two uh sub problems
uh so uh why I need it here because uh I
uh will require um uh if I have
equalities like in h theorem then uh I
will end up with n recurrence uh
possibly and so I need to avoid this uh
situation yes and I guess I'm puzzled by
the strict properness of the subset I
mean why that's not
necessary oh because of the uh
assumption on the arrival process that
at each time step there is exactly one
uh item that uh that comes from the
demand side and from the supply side so
it's already there but if I had a
perfect matching and I had one extra
node that was not separated I could
handle anything that was n minus one on
one side and I couldn't handle n on the
other but this is a stochastic thing so
if you're precisely at the
threshold oh but maybe it comes back to
the connectiveness now I'm just
wondering that it's easy to match n nus1
with nus one but you you know if you're
not
testing a Noe a Noe an nth node on on
the opposite
side but then I will not be able to if
I'm just uh ignoring one node
uh I will uh
um I cannot have the condition satisfied
for the uh let's say I remove one Supply
node I look at the other Supply uh nodes
uh because of the arrival uh rate on of
supply and demand being equal it will uh
directly not satisfy the uh um the uh
necessary condition but uh I'll just try
to go uh through the optimization and
then uh uh we can uh uh uh have a longer
discussion later so
uh uh as uh we assume that we have a
linear cost function on the uh buffer
size of the buffer sizes and we consider
average uh cost so uh uh Q Dynamics you
have a state of uh I mean Vector
describing the
um uh the size of Q's uh QT then a uh
denotes arrival at time T and and this
is the matching uh activities that uh uh
your policy will make uh and there are
some restriction on this uh uh process
UT uh it has to uh uh be
a uh linear combination of um uh edges
so uh and uh uh then uh we consider the
uh policies uh that uh that will be a a
function of the sum of the actual Q size
and the newly arriv arrived uh items so
this is uh denoted by X and uh uh so
uh now we can uh frame this as an mdp uh
problem uh for the uh uh process X and
uh
uh one of the first questions uh uh that
uh uh in analyzing of queing systems uh
that you might ask is uh what is the
workload process and here is something
that looks quite uh unusual uh so uh how
do you
uh okay let me just uh C you through
this so uh usually you define workload
process as uh the amount of work needed
uh to empty the system if you stop
arrivals
right so here uh why this is nontrivial
if you stop
arrivals and you do not have uh
uh a perfect matching uh configuration
then nothing will ever happen so it's
actually just the new arrivals that uh
help you empty the
system and uh so
uh here uh the the uh and our
constraints uh on the System Dynamics
are given by this uh um inequalities uh
uh in nond so uh natural workload
process is expressed in um in terms of
these constraints so take any subset for
example d uh and look at the difference
between uh the items in the subset minus
the uh items on the supply side that can
get matched with this
demand
okay
so now uh we will uh in order to uh have
some insight on the uh uh good policy in
this uh in this setting we will consider
uh heavy traffic consumption uh uh here
assume that there is one uh demand
subset that uh uh is the most critical
uh so that in in the sense that the
difference uh in the arrival rate for
that man set and Supply items uh uh that
can be matched with them uh goes to uh
zero
okay and uh
uh so uh once again in our case workload
uh is uh something that is not trivial
so it can have positive and negative
value this is similar to inventory
systems so uh
uh some insights will uh come from uh
from there and uh uh
so noted that uh uh another very
interesting property of these matching
models is uh that is very easy to avoid
idleness so uh in order to uh because
the most in most cases the the biggest
concern is how to make sure that we can
always idle so you need some safety
stocks sitting there to achieve that uh
and here
uh in order to avoid idleness just don't
do
anything okay so the uh idleness here
corresponds to matching between uh uh
the supply items that can serve D and
the complement so that's idleness here
so very easy to
avoid okay and uh uh so um in order to
um have an Insight on the uh good
policies here we will do two types of
relaxation uh first of uh relaxation is
that we will uh concentrate only on the
uh workload process for the uh critical
demand Set uh it's symmetrical if you
consider Supply so I'll uh just consider
demand here and uh then uh the second
relaxation will be a um going to the uh
continuous uh
uh space so okay uh now
um I will only consider what happens for
uh that given workload process and uh uh
then I can uh just uh uh I mean my new
Dynamics becomes this so this is arrival
rate uh my idleness and then I'm left
with some
uh that has zero
mean and uh then uh for we said that we
have linear cost function uh so um if
I'm uh now I now need to Define what is
my cost for this workload relaxation and
this will be noted by a uh effective
cost and uh uh it's just a very simple
linear program and uh if C is linear uh
the solution is uh actually just a p
wice linear uh cost
function okay and now uh so uh the
second
uh uh ingredient will will be going uh
to the uh um now we have this
onedimensional process so we can use uh
results of uh I mean U some ideas of
inventory uh models uh similar to Clark
and scurve and uh uh um the uh uh
approxim continuous approximation by
reflected Brown in motion gives us
actually the value of uh uh suggest uh
that uh uh we will need to look into uh
threshold policy and that the threshold
uh value of the threshold uh will be of
this
form okay so I'm out of time so I'll try
to uh uh uh give you just the flavor of
the main result under some technical
assumptions here that I don't expect you
to read uh just to tell you that uh uh
uh high level this one is uh uh the
first assumption is that there was only
one critical V uh uh workload Vector uh
so the others are uh
bounded uh and uh uh I mean the uh
arrival rate for the others is uh uh is
bounded by something that is uh uh uh
negative and then there are some uh
continuity assumption uh and also there
is uh third assumption is that uh uh uh
on the graph structure um that we need
connectivity even when we at at the
limit when Delta goes to zero and we
need to be able to
idle there need to be one uh Edge
between uh s of D and uh d complement
under these uh
conditions uh it turns out that uh uh we
are able uh uh I mean that the U
um following type of policies that we uh
uh call uh age max weight with threshold
for obvious reasons uh uh gives us uh
ASM totic optimality with bounded regret
so uh
uh first what is uh H max weight well it
is uh max weight with a given well
chosen function uh H and then on top of
that we have this uh uh
threshold uh behavior that comes from
links with the inventory uh
systems so uh and with the uh high level
idea is apply uh h max
weight if
um but if your uh workload uh
um uh is uh higher than uh the threshold
then just forbid uh idling so you never
idle until workload goes very
negative you Lo this certain threshold
that is given by the uh uh approximation
by the reflected Brown in motion
okay so
uh it's also interesting that uh um so
here um this is the optimal policy uh
this is the
um
uh and this is uh the
uh the optimal average cost for the
workload uh
relaxation uh and but that is still
stochastic but then using the uh as I
already uh mentioned using the um
continuous approximation with reflected
Brown motion you can actually uh compute
the value of uh uh this uh threshold and
then also the uh approximate the uh uh
the value of the uh average cost with uh
this term that does not depend on
Delta okay so
uh some uh idea on what H is uh it's a
combination of two terms one is a
function of workload and it's uh it's uh
also obtained from the uh this uh
workload relaxation and uh uh um links
with uh uh diffusion and then uh the
second term uh induces uh penalty uh if
you are deviating uh too much your
actual cost is deviating from this
effective
cost okay um so I was just trying to get
some intuition behind the threshold
excuse me so is it are you suggesting
that by creating this threshold you're
ensuring that matchings are big enough
when you serve them if you were serving
them without the threshold you would be
serving very few edges whereas by
creating a threshold you are creating a
sort of big matching before serving uh
threshold is there to uh avoid uh cross
matchings between uh what is uh capable
of serving your critical uh subset and
uh uh and the uh the rest of the demand
so it's not uh there to create a more uh
bigger population to perform matchings
but to avoid that you uh
um it's some in some sort uh uh creating
reserves for your um for your critical
uh work CL and you can automatically
detect that threshold or you need to
know which is the bottleneck in order to
that's another story so so far we assume
that we know what is the bottleneck and
then uh and then uh uh if uh uh if you
don't know that then you need to uh plug
on top of that some learning me
mechanism to uh to know uh the AR to to
learn theal arrival rates and then uh
identify what is the uh uh bottleneck in
your system uh okay uh so here is uh one
example um of a simple NN model and uh
um okay uh we considered here that the
workload uh Vector corresponds to this
node so uh uh the workload relaxation
tracks uh the difference uh of uh uh
what is here and what can get match to
them and uh uh then uh so here is the
cost function uh and uh the uh this
threshold estimation of the threshold is
around uh 15 and then if you're actually
around the system with uh uh this
thresold policy you get much better
results than just using max
weight uh and uh uh basically uh these
are just first results uh I hope but uh
by understanding um even under these uh
strange conditions on the arrival
process and uh uh looking at uh the
heavy traffic setting this might give us
some insight how the optimal policy
might look like in the general case so
uh with some uh I have some hope that
then this uh can uh guide us to have
some um supervised learning uh um that
uh that can uh be efficient here so so
it's a uh the important building block
and understanding uh the channel uh
picture and uh this will be very
important uh when we go to Applications
because here we ignored the many of the
uh uh many other features that might
come uh with uh uh other applications
and so there are many many open
questions uh uh for example what happens
if you um if you U have a more complex
arrival processes uh will you put some
uh will just let people leave and
abandon and just try to minimize this
abandonment rate or you will put into
place some admission control to the
system um some maybe pricing schemes
even I think Sean would not like that uh
and uh also there are applications that
might require non- bip parted uh
matching models and there are some
results uh for the stability here but uh
there is many other things to be
done yes um does the usual sum of qze
squ turn out to be a leap function for
Max rate here or do you need some other
cl to get so for the stability uh um
it's uh it's exactly what you think so
it's a uh quadratical function but it's
uh not very easy to prove it directly uh
for the max weight uh policy uh in order
to prove the uh um bounded drift for
quadratic G function you need to
construct some
auxiliary um randomized matching policy
for which it's that is U Guided by the
um uh fluid uh approximation so it's uh
it comes from the N um Network flow
problems and then for once you'd get it
for this obviously then max weight uh uh
minimizes the uh in that case if you
switched instead to using Q to the alpha
for some very small value of alpha as a
leapa function and just picked the
steepest Descent of that that that
algorithm works extremely well for in
the generalized switch case where the
serving is deterministic I'm wondering
if it would end up working extremely
well here
also we so um yeah I uh I think that
here uh the uh this uh I
mean if we are in the setting that we
considered there is a dominant uh work
uh set that is I mean critical set that
you need to pay attention at then I
think the threshold is really important
well component when when there's only
one critical thing and you know what it
is then the problem is basically easy
you you the only job of the threshold as
as as s was saying is to make sure you
stay there but um when when you don't
know what it is or or when there may be
multiple thresholds which are critical
um then then it's trickier and and then
the weird thing is that that um you know
the the the queing system itself doesn't
know which which one is is critical it
it will have random fluctuations which
push it into which are like someone is
critical then some and and so the the
different policies seem to work the the
good policies are good because they are
robust to all circumstance and all
circumstances do arise just playing from
random fluctuations so I cannot believe
that the threshold is is absolutely
vital in a formal limit of of some sort
but but for for any system which has
when you're trying to take out of all of
the fluctuations then
essentially will see all all critical
regimes and Serv work well under all
critical regimes that well that's my
intuition from the the deterministic
cas so I don't know I need to think
about uh more but uh What uh like uh if
you it is interesting that uh this uh in
this example here we actually didn't
consider Delta to be very small it's a
it was just smaller than the others and
it was not very uh close to this uh to
this limit and still it perform
considerably better than just max V so I
think that this uh threshold can play a
role even if you're not uh limit cost I
mean yeah and that's that's a good uh I
mean if it change the cost then of
course everything will
change so I kind of go to my biis with
ver things you got this nice work that
sort of looks into reversibility of
these systems then you go into this
Dynamic M bipartite matching model and I
was wondering if are the reversible
Dynamics there um you
know I mean the issue essentially with
max weight if there's any form of
feedback in the system is going to lose
its stability properties uh so max
weight has issues that if you it's not
single he lose it stability whereas if
it's reversible then you don't get that
anymore so you know you got a patient
you treat them they need to come for a
second period of treatment Max going be
on so so uh uh I take as the um uh as a
message that uh uh as long as single hop
uh I'm I'm fine but if uh if uh I'm
going into multihop systems then it
might be worth uh to consider uh even uh
storing more information but having a
stability it's got the same performance
even better performance in lot situation
and Max so so then you can preserve the
reversibility properties from the first
to the second so what is interesting
here that uh um uh I didn't I don't have
the the plots for this case but uh first
com first served was very similar to uh
Max weting for this particular example
now we don't include multihop systems so
that uh yeah that might be the case but
uh it was performing slightly better in
general but uh but uh it still had very
um very uh large Q
sizes think we're eating into our break
lot maybe can yeah there are technical
issues I think we can have break
left so if you have
any if you have any suggestions of uh
applications uh just uh let me know that
might uh give some ideas of what uh
variant of the model it's worth to
consider
so